[Music]
there's a small neighborhood in montreal
known as my land which has become an
unlikely hub for gaming companies it is
now a neighborhood where that has a high
concentration of people who work in game
development
the mile end is the home of some of the
most creative and most recognized game
ideas in the history of modern video
games
one of these is minority media a company
that's the catalyst for a burgeoning
video game genre called empathy gaming
where players are forced to confront
real human issues like bullying
alcoholism or depression
gamers place themselves in the shoes of
the character to feel and try and
understand what they are going through
what
we're trying to do here is we're trying
to put
people in a different mindset we're
trying to put people into a different
perspective
as canadians we're
used to being able to
put ourselves in other people's shoes
we're used to
looking at things from a different
perspective
gaming can be for anybody for everybody
we're taking advantage of the
educational possibilities we've
developed a language game for
a school board up in northern quebec
they've approached us to do a game for
the grade 1 students we've worked with
the curriculum that they've established
we've developed a story behind that and
made that into a game
empathy games themselves have become a
less exclusive genre and have integrated
themselves into
bigger games and so empathy games have
influenced the way bigger games are made
now there is
room to go a lot deeper into what gaming
can actually be
there's a universe of possibilities
and so i think we've only just begun
scratching the surface